on beaches like this one outside of
Kaliningrad precious gemstone amber is
so plentiful you might simply find it
washed up in the sand
amber is actually fossilized tree sap
that's 50 million years old
ninety percent of the world's supply of
ahthe comes from right here in
Kaliningrad amber is big business
mined and massive quarries using
pressurized water the most valuable
pieces are first sorted by size then
polished with wooden cubes and huge
rotating machines to remove impurities
shaped by hands using powerful saws and
then prepared for manufacture to ship
out to artisans and jewelers all around
the world the best of their work over
the past centuries is housed here at the
cities amber Museum have attitudes
towards amber changed in recent times
people started to assemble in Russia in
10th century it was as precious as gold
but the attitude is changing because
before the attitude was like oh it's a
stone of my grandmother because it was
very popular in 60s but now even local
young people who are wearing jewelry
sleight of hand to see some of these new
styles I decided to pay a visit to a
local jewelry designer who specialized
in making customized new designs for the
next generation
they really are cutting-edge they use 3d
modeling to create a design then use wax
models to create plaster casts filled
with molten silver amber pieces are
sorted by exact shades of color polished
to a brilliant shine and then laser
soldered into place it really was quite
impressive
so when you come to the amber capital of
the world you know exactly what to bring
home as a souvenir it's the perfect gift
for someone you love
[Music]